okay so let's get going with our Jenga
pieces quick backstory we have been
doing this thing where when people make
contributions at patreon.com slash david
pakman show for every two contributions
I move a Jenga piece we have currently
moved twenty-one pieces that corresponds
by doubling that number twenty-one
becomes a 42 percent membership discount
code if I am unable to move any more
pieces whatever the final number of
pieces I can move before the Jenga tower
falls that number gets doubled and we
create a membership discount so I we've
got five pieces to move today and I'm
gonna get right into it Pat's gonna help
me out with the names of the people and
I I'm worried today it's going to fall
but let's get right into it Pat who are
the first two names johan Bartling and
rick norse okay johan and rick is there
a piece here that i can easily move
without it getting to here's one I've
got from the top all right one we are
now up to 22 pieces what are the next
two names david headings and Teagan lit
cot David and Tegan all right let's see
if there's a piece here it is really
getting to the bottom now wow that one
is that that's not a good one to move
here's one very very carefully and you
can see how carefully I am doing this
because we are at 22 pieces and I am
just sliding it out and we are at 23
pieces a 46 percent discount Pat what
are the next two names
we got Richard Davis and Corey Easterday
Richard and Corey let's see if I can
find a piece to move oh my this is
getting Pat is nervous over there Pat is
really really nervous here it is and
that is now 24 or which gets us a 48
percent discount what are the next two
names
Imelda West and Christina hassle bad
Imelda and Christina
Imelda and Christina what could I do
what about this one oh wow and that one
goes on top and that is now 25 pieces a
50% discount if I'm unable to go further
Pat what are the next two names last
ones Darrell Takhar and Michael Leone
Darrell and Michael will Darrell Darrell
and Michael be the end of this
Wow I don't know if it's smart to pull
one from the bottom but I've done it
almost oh and the entire thing just
moved and I am placing it on top which
gets us to 26 moves a 52 percent
discount if it were to fall it continues
are you shocked that it's gone this far
yeah and it could just fall during the
course of the show - yeah and if that if
it happens during the course of the Joad
show just from my gesticulating then it
will still be the 52 percent membership
discount all right so contribute to the
Jenga game by going to patreon.com slash
david pakman show and making a
contribution and we'll continue tomorrow
and see how long this nonsense can go on